un discours de l'engagement de
mobilisation fait de lucidité sur la
difficulté d'affronter le réel
l'ensemble des réformes qu'il faudra
mener pendant pendant ce quinquennat pas
d'autosatisfaction mais au contraire une
volonté déterminée
j'ai trouvé dans le discours du premier
ministre à la fois du fond de
l'engagement mais aussi une forme
d'élégance politique qui est rare en
politique palais à de françois de rugy
non je parle parle non je pars
d'élégance politique donc dans le propos
dans les termes dans la culture dans les
références auxquelles premier ministre
fait fait allusion
je trouve qu'il a il n'est pas seulement
sûr de son fait
avec la volonté de d'avancé mais il a
rappelé aussi je crois le lien qu'il a
avec le chef de l'état la fonction de
fonctionne exécutif la relation qui
entre le gouvernement et le parlement
avec je le dis avec avec sourire avec
émotion aussi et dans le même temps avec
détermination et je pense que après
avoir écouté les et les parlementaires
autour de moi tout le monde s'est senti
j'allais dire regonfler
certains m'ont dit ça fait du bien
d'entendre ce discours donc la majorité
les parlementaires députés comme
sénateurs vont incarner cette unité que
réclame le gouvernement qui réclame
l'exécutif pour le soutenir
il m'a semblé que la gouverne de l'unité
n'a jamais fait défaut qu' il peut y
avoir des divergences d'appréciation ya
jamais eu de fondeurs dans les rangs des
marcheurs y en a pas aujourd'hui a pas
de ya pas deux
j'allais dire de fronde vis-à-vis du
gouvernement aucune et dans le même
temps est ce qu'on remarque au bout d'un
an il n'y a pas de telle ou telle
ministre qui est mis en exergue
critiques et aux autres que l'ensemble
du gouvernement est perçu dans son unité
et moi je je suis fier de voir que un an
après j'ai rarement vu un exécutif
fonctionner aussi bien entre le lien qui
a entre la rive gauche et la rive droite
elysée et matignon fonctionne toujours
avec la même efficacité et le moderne
c'est au poursuit les réformes surtout
je pense que s'ils ont reculé
aujourd'hui on perdrait tout si on
avance on pourra continuer à gagner